que ce soit et le losc jeff bezos ce
bernard arnault les 10 hommes les plus
fortunés de la planète s'en sont mis
plein les poches depuis le début de la
pandémie
selon un rapport de luigi oxfam leurs
avoirs sont passés de 700 à 1500
milliards de dollars ceux qui sont hors
de prix mais l'entreprise et au doublé
leur fortune les 10 hommes les plus
riches pendant que la majorité des gens
ont vu leurs achats
ne pouvant profiter de jute gains en
bourse comme les hyper riches 160
millions personnes ont basculé dans la
pauvreté depuis mars 2020 à l'échelle
planétaire
la pandémie a causé des pertes d'emplois
est fort c'est certain mais surtout
certaines à rester à la maison et
beaucoup de femmes ont dû arrêter leur
travail leur façon d gagner leur vie
pour ce qui est des personnes mal à
s'occuper d'eux
au canada les 59 milliardaire du pays
ont vu leur fortune globale grimpé de
plus de moitié mais l'écart entre le
revenu disponible des 10% de la
population les plus fortunés et celui
des 10% les plus pauvres s'est rétréci
il est passé de 46 à 43 % depuis le
début de la pandémie donc en fait on est
au plus petit écart jamais enregistré
depuis
1999 c'est l'effet des mesures de
soutien du gouvernement et de la
redistribution de la richesse et
mécanismes de redistribution via les
impôts et les transports permettent de
mitiger s'est décalé et de revenir à des
décors qui sont assez stables somme
toute à travers le temps évidemment
c'est pas une situation idéale là on
aimerait mieux que les gens puissent
avoir des revenus de travail plus égaux
comment à aider les autres dans le code
et 2,6 et crédit
reste qu' il ya beaucoup de gens qui
font un peu du sentiment de pouvoir
d'achat par exemple on sait qu'il est
facile portante mais les gens qui sont
allés au minimum aussi
pour récupérer une partie de l'argent
qui engrange les hyper riches oxfam
réclame la mise en place d'impôts sur la
fortune et le capital
mais pour que certains payent leur juste
part il faudra lutter contre les
échappatoires et les paradis fiscaux ici
olivier bachar radio canada montréal